hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today marks the four-year
anniversary of my time on this channel
and coincidentally today is also the day
that I'm going to be hitting 13 million
subscribers on YouTube and that's
phenomenal
that's amazing that's such an enormous
number and to celebrate it I have come
up with a very stupid idea that I call
the fire and ice challenge I have 13
habanero peppers right here that I'm
going to be eating while I'm in this ice
bath and then once I'm done with the
peppers I'm going to be reacting to an
old video of mine it is actually the
first time I ever had face cam so if
you're ready I'm not ready but here we
go fire my head
blue bowl my epic YouTube is a bad idea
you catching that seeing this glory oh
my god okay so I'm going to start out
with I'm gonna try to eat four of them
at first just to get it out of the way
and then I'm gonna get in the bath and
I'm going to continually pop them down
I'm gonna try to get it quick if you can
count that's that's 13 of them of
various sizes huh you want something
case you vomit like a trash bag or
something that's a good idea to keep up
are you ready
mmm-hmm am I ready are you all ready
three two one
don't know if it's so hot so cold all
the weird thing in the world
oh hell I did that for more I gotta get
down
wah oh no dad I did it I did it
Oh God give me this one Oh before I mama
weird okay oh my god to me this was so
long ago how long ago oh my god oh my
god aah oh my god
nothing much in there in years
hi because I can whoa it's so you don't
know this survey sensations are paid
unlike anything I've ever seen before in
my life
for years all line up Dylan Bowman in my
life for years culminating to do this
one way if you love it
where are the demands immediately over
okay okay oh it wasn't it wasn't it oh
so cold what are you laughing at you
forget out all I'm scared oh I need to
keep reacting to me that is really this
is a custom story revolutions light
booyakasha the latest on that side devil
Corinthian I'm creeped out by lighting
throat do you that I'm scared it also
grave
obviously I remember that and we cover
everything up with a false sense of
insecurity why do I hate mannequin so
much can you say beta cos la you keep
still doing Oh
good good good my girlfriend in chair
gonna get some I used to love the chair
this sure was my jam oh I'm gonna get
out I'm alright how you dude I survived
that was bad
oh man who's such a blind fury of
burning I was trying my best to like say
things but every breath was like poison
fire the ice was chilling everything
below the way so it was the weirdest
mixture of sensations I've never had my
brain assaulted with so many feelings
before I'm gonna be paying for this
later holy [ __ ]
Oh red that's right I had brevet just
thank you guys so much for being with me
for four years straight and it was
really cool to see an old video of mine
cuz is funny I
I look back and whatever I see an old
video line I instantly been taken to the
time that I recorded it I remember where
I was in my life and I remember also how
shy I was in that video you guys may not
be able to tell but or maybe you can
tell I'm really nervous in that video
and it's just really cool to see how far
I've come as a person and how far I've
come out of my own shyness and back then
like I could like me going in front of a
camera was amazingly brave for me not
for anyone else but for who I was at the
time I didn't talk to anybody I didn't
go out I didn't have friends that I hang
out with all the time I like when I had
friends obviously but you know I was a
very introverted person and to see that
old me and to be proud of you know the
choices that I made it and to be proud
of where I am even though lemon if it is
[ __ ] here but it's it's it's fun and
it's it's been a rewarding four years
and I look forward to a lot more cool
[ __ ] so thank you for being with me for
four years and thank you for thirteen
million subscribers I'm gonna go before
I throw up so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye